we are days away now from yet another
hearing in the pua
dieter lawsuit this week we're going to
learn more about what kind of changes
that dieter is working on
joe mohler spoke to the attorney who is
representing the claimants
he's live tonight with what that
attorney is saying about a recent mass
denial of claims
joe
that's right we talked about those mass
denials and what people should be doing
when it comes to appealing those denials
now mark thurman the attorney in this
case says he also has requests from
some of you ahead of thursday's hearing
you've been waiting for a long time uh
yeah that's a lot of weight brett shane
blonjet and his wife terry bloodjet are
only getting unemployment benefits from
one of their jobs
brett got a denial letter recently
around the same time thousands of others
did
he appealed that i was able to download
all of my documents to prove
you know the situation uh i got a
confirmation number and so on and now
it just says wait now all they can do is
hope something happens
before the eviction moratorium is lifted
a real concern of theirs
to the extent you can appeal appeal most
people can appeal
mark thurman is the attorney
representing claimants in the pua dieter
lawsuit
after a recent mass denial of claims he
said his office was contacted by
many people what they did was to look to
david did to make his statistics look
better and say oh yeah we're processing
lots of claims well we'll deny them
that's that's their definition of
processing we're just not
not even pending for you know 22 weeks
or or 16 weeks depending if you're a
good worker or not
he says it is important for people to
appeal when they can
if you can't appeal it that way try it
in writing it doesn't hurt
i i i could i mean the appeal process is
it's going nowhere anyway but at least
you covered yourself so they can't say
aha you didn't appeal
the next year separate thursday thurman
says he is looking to hear from gig
workers who had their benefits stopped
and never reinstated i have over 400
people telling me that they
started to receive payments and then
stopped and those payments were not re
uh you know restored like the order said
it should be i'd like more examples
now if you were in that scenario that
therman just explained they want to hear
from you via email we have the link up
on our website that's 8newsnow.com
also on this story if you click that in
addition to that email you'll also find
a helpful video for those of you who
have questions about the appeals process
reporting live i'm joe mohler i'll